[Music]
hi everyone sal khan here i've always
been drawn to creative things i like to
see change new things in the world and
because of that i've been drawn to
careers where i can most apply my
creativity especially in an abstract
sense and algebra is perhaps the purest
expression of creativity and that's why
i've worked in everything from computer
programming to
product design to
a a hedge fund analyst where you're
investing in stocks and all of them it
was incredibly creative and used a lot
of algebra but don't take my word for it
you're going to meet some of my friends
who can tell you a lot more about the
connection between algebra and work and
creativity
i think my idea of how creativity works
and stem jobs has
changed since i've gotten to college
like i used to think that like all the
mathematicians would be just locked away
in some like office and like typing on
the computers or writing down equations
by themselves they coming up with
incredibly beautiful ideas just by
themselves but i'm realizing now that
i'm in college that
i mathematics and creativity it's a lot
about communication and it's a lot about
trying to build off of each other's
ideas and balance ideas ideas off of
each other um and build upon um
ideas that have already been made by
people decades ago
and i think that the facts that we all
come with it with our own perspectives
and different
ideas and different ways of being
creative create allows math to advance
further because we can all combine our
creative ideas into something bigger we
collect data on
everything right and so the ability to
use that data in a
smart safe and efficient way depends on
new applications of mathematical
concepts to these new and innovative
data sets
as we get to that point we'll start to
be thinking outside the box a lot more
and we'll be a much more innovative
digital society but that can't happen
unless we start trying to be creative
and not just rely on tried and true
creativity is really important for me as
like a future job as a part of my future
job i would want to
do something that changes and then i can
use problem solving skills constantly um
i feel like when i make animations or
when i figure out how to explain
something
i'm
really like that i love that because
it's there's so many different solutions
but knowing that you can try to find and
experiment with different ones and maybe
create something beautiful is um really
i don't know inspiring to me
mathematicals is an educational
initiative that i co-founded with fellow
mathematician jess williams and what
we're trying to do is make maths fun and
accessible and encourage more girls to
pursue careers in maths
so creativity is essential here because
we're trying to think of ways that
people will will enjoy maths and and it
will be fun and accessible to them
so different creative techniques that
we've been using are trying to present
mathematical
problems in fun short videos and that
explain the problem in a way that
everybody will understand and will make
them want to learn more and discover
more about the topics that we're talking
about i'm really lucky
that i get to be creative every day
in my work and i have been since
i got into this field of data science so
in general across the last decade my
work has really been about
designing and testing innovative ways to
capture human behavior within game-based
assessments
so my collaborators and i from the time
i was in graduate school to now use a
variety of different modeling techniques
from various fields we'll pull things
from engineering
aerospace um you know more basic
mathematical models to help us achieve
this goal we get to think outside the
box we get to think about how we can
pull in different types of thinking from
different fields to help us better
understand
human behavior human cognition
learning
so it's really exciting and really novel
and it's something that because of the
field that i'm in i've been able to do
this now for for multiple years
whenever i want to have a salute come up
with a solution to a problem and i don't
have it
my immediate like reaction is to go
outside and go on a walk um i love
walking in all kinds of weather i it's
kind of um it's
just i feel like with the peace and calm
like getting a weight moving away from
the problem and stepping away from it
sometimes i get way better ideas and it
inspires me
but i also think there's something to be
said about
not being inspired like not always it's
amazing i feel like sometimes
i get
struck with inspiration for how i want
to explain a khan academy video or how i
want to approach a piece of art or how i
want to
approach a math problem but sometimes it
doesn't come and so i feel like what the
best solution is when you are trying to
get into that creative zone and you
can't it's just do it and
try to do something anyway like
write something or write your equations
try to figure it out and if you make
mistakes that's okay and because it's
something to jump off of and maybe
sometimes seeing what you already know
down on paper can help you come up with
better ideas and can help you be more
creative forcing yourself to just
conjure a solution simply does not work
instead take a break from the task pick
something else up like physical sport or
even video games and then come back to
the original problem that can do wonders
[Music]
one of my biggest passions is
documentary filmmaking i've been making
videos since i was in middle school and
i remember being
real it was always a challenge because
sometimes i wanted to do things but i
didn't have the equipment to do it like
i really wanted to um
record myself in a certain way but there
was no way for me for anyone to hold the
microphone or i didn't have a dolly or
any of the expensive camera equipment so
what i i remember like i think the most
important thing to do is just use what
you have so i would tape like a a
cross-country ski pole to my ceiling and
hold the microphone that way um or i
would put my phone my a pillow in a box
and then speak into the microphone with
that as my makeshift like sound studio
or uh make a tripod out of like a style
uh like a pile of books um and i feel
like
it's kind of the same with math like you
are
sometimes you don't know how to solve a
really big problem um and you only have
all the tools you've been taught up to
that point and maybe there is like a
fancier way of getting to the solution
but a lot of the time it's just about
combining things that you already have
in your um that you've already learned
and coming up with a solution that way
and sometimes that comes up with some
like really creative and unexpected
solutions
to problems
[Music]
algebra is
really the unifying thread of almost all
of mathematics
you may think algebra is boring
but it is the one tool you can use to
not only understand but unlock the
universe
creative algebra is used in computer
game design it
powers how artificial intelligence works
mastering algebra will provide you with
the ability to decode and understand
many complex systems
in my opinion
if you can master algebra you can master
anything
you